tornados have damaged parts of the US
for 13 straight days now and another
round of severe weather is expected
today twisters hit parts of North Texas
yesterday ripping down fences uprooting
trees and pulling shingles off roofs
Mireya Villarreal is in Canton Texas
that's about 60 miles east of Dallas
Maria what's a damaged look like where
you are well hey good morning guys take
a look people here are actually saying
they think they dodged a bullet but that
is even with a tornado hitting what you
said Canton area this is the damage that
it left behind this is a business here
just off the Main Street the windows
have been blown out the roof has come
down these these machines back here
obviously destroyed right now the storms
have finally moved through this area
giving people just enough time to pick
up the pieces before the next storm
comes through Oh power flashes power
flashes on the road right in front of us
for the 13th day in a row
tornado sirens blared from Pennsylvania
to Texas failed a half second it was
just an exception and I just prayed a
lot menacing twisters were on the move
in parts of Texas Wednesday
ripping trees from the ground tossing
them on cars and blowing up the windows
of these businesses in Canton parts of
this gas station were shredded by the
violent winds people emerge from their
storm shelters to find a trail of
destruction you can see the rain I mean
it was hammering down the street we
could say the vehicles shaken in Preston
Berg Kentucky 70 mile-per-hour winds
through the roof off this building and
into the street killing a man who was
driving through farther north in New
Jersey and Pennsylvania seriously looked
like something out of a movie people are
describing a war zone left behind by
twisters and flash flooding by the time
we turned around to get to our basement
it was over it was that fast crews have
been working throughout the night to get
power back up and running to parts of
Canton that were affected the good news
is rain is not expected here for the
next few days but the storm that came
through here blew all of this stuff
around it is expected to head east
dumping more rain hail high winds and
also some possible tornadoes in central
and northeast parts of the country Gale
I'm gonna hang on to the words you said
there is some good news there Thank You
Matteo thank you very much